Avengers infinity war is one of Marvel's
most intense and emotional movies ever
with an ending that's loaded with
consequences for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's
Jan here and in this video I'm breaking
down the shocking ending to Avengers
infinity war as well as explaining some
Easter eggs and theories and what they
mean for Avengers 4 don't forget my
Avengers Funko pop giveaway is running
so make sure you're a subscriber and
leave me a comment about the movie for a
chance to win obviously spoilers ahead
if you haven't seen the movie let's
start with the snap yes this was when
the horrifying moment teased by Gamora
towards the start of the film came true
after Thanos snapped his fingers in the
gauntlet around half of our heroes
disintegrated one by one into ash like a
slow-motion nightmare comic book fans
will recognize this as the iconic snap
moment from the Infinity Gauntlet comics
where the Mad Tyson snapped his fingers
and half the universe including half the
Marvel superheroes disappeared it's a
shocking moment because as an audience
when we watch a typical superhero movie
or action movie even we often expect the
hero to come in at the final moments and
save the day with the glorious act of
heroism it was incredibly powerful to
watch each hero make a final stand
against the mad Titan and then to seethe
anos just swat each one aside like they
were nothing even Captain America who
was the last hero standing between
Thanos getting to wander and vision it
was gut-wrenching to then see wonder end
vision before Thanos brought him back
and killed him again but this time with
appalling brutality as he ripped out the
mind stone and despite Thor having
warned Thanos at the start that he died
for what he'd done to the house
Guardians even thaws magnificent
entrance and blow to Thanos's chest with
Stormbreaker wasn't enough the ending we
expect as an audience is pretty much
overturned as basically the Avengers
lose to the very big bad and if you look
back at the previous MCU movies for
example age of Ultron you can see how
this moment was foreshadowed with
Avengers we can bust arms dealers on the
live long day but that up there that's
that's the again
how are you guys planning on beating
that together
we'll lose and we'll do that together
too so although cap and Tony are still
separated geographically at the end of
infinity war in a way they did both
fight Thanos together one in Wakanda and
the other on Titan but to truly defeat
Thanos in Avengers for Tony and cap are
going to have to bring some balance back
to their own relationship and before the
credits roll the movie ends with the
scene of Thanos looking out over a
beautiful green and fertile land on the
surface it looks like he's won he's
achieved balance in the universe and
he's finally stopping to rest and as he
said earlier watched the Sun Rise on a
grateful universe in fact the way that
ass talks about wanting time out after
he's finished his plan in the movie has
shades of how he goes on to live a quiet
life as farmer Thanos in the comics and
the film's closing scene also mirrors
this image at the end of the Infinity
Gauntlet comics but even though Thanos
smiles to himself in the movie I think
there's a lot more to this ending that's
hidden beneath the surface for a start
let's remember that the original
Avengers are still alive and I think
that what Tony Stark said to Loki in the
first Avengers movie is going to be
important for what happens next
you're missing the point there's no
throne there is no version of this where
you come out on top maybe your army
comes and maybe it's too much for us but
it's all on you if we can't protect the
air if you can be damn well sure we'll
avenge it I suspect that means an
Avengers for the heroes that have
survived will become literal Avengers
they'll be angry and driven to figure
out how to find and take revenge on
Thanos for everyone he's taken away from
them and as Thor said in this movie rage
revenge anger loss or regret are all
tremendous motivators and I wonder if a
possible title for the next movie
therefore could be Avengers reassembled
from Marvel Studios point of view it
also means the actors whose contracts
are expiring like Robert Downey jr. and
Chris Evans can go out with a really big
bang perhaps even sacrificing themselves
to bring back those who disappeared you
hope for the best then make do with what
you get I got a great team
nothing lasts forever and because the
snap means a lot of characters have
vanished it leaves room for characters
like Hawkeye ant-man and wasp who didn't
get a part in infinity war to come in
for a significant role in Avengers 4 on
top of this there are some very
important moments in infinity war where
Clues were dropped on how the Avengers
will be able to climb out of this
desperate situation first of all think
back to that moment when Doctor Strange
went forward in time and checked more
than 14 million possibilities for an
outcome in which the Avengers won
strange told Tony that there was just
one scenario in which that happened
later when the fight against Thanos went
south and the mad Titan was about to
kill Iron Man Doctor Strange made a
bargain with Thanos to trade the time
stone for Tony's life but remember
earlier on the Q ship strange had been
adamant that if it came to saving them
all the time stone he would not hesitate
to let Tony or Peter Parker die so it's
clear that strangers action of trading
Tony's life for the time stone was a
very deliberate decision by the sorcerer
supreme
notice how strange also said were in the
endgame now after he handed the stone
over which is an echo of Tony's words
and age of Ultron about his vision which
means that Strange knew that giving the
time stone to Thanos was the only
scenario in which Thanos could be
defeated this was emphasized when just
before fading away strange told Tony
there was no other way a big hint and
hopefully a clue that Tony will pick up
on that giving up the time stone to
Thanos will in time lead to the Mad
Titans defeat that future timeline that
Doctor Strange foresaw needed Thanos to
get all six Infinity stones and for Tony
Stark to remain alive by the way
apparently Benedict Cumberbatch who
plays Doctor Strange was one of the few
casts you got to read the full infinity
war script and he said it was because
his character had to understand the
context of all the events and that dr.
Strange's responsibility is to protect
the multiverse and hold it together I
think that in Avengers 4 our heroes will
need to figure out the losses true
weakness which we had hints of in
infinity war for example there was a
small cut that Ironman landed on
thanassis face during the fight on titan
as well as Stannis's torn to thaw that
he should have gone for his head with
storm breaker and intriguingly after the
snap when Thanos reappeared the Infinity
Gauntlet seemed to have burned up or
been damaged in some way suggesting
another possible weakness their one
vital theme which runs throughout
infinity war and is necessary to really
understand the story is that the film is
all about the cost of being a hero the
theme of the movie is about what does it
cost to be hero in a complicated world
and does the cost of you know there's a
value of doing what's right outweigh the
cost
this is a thread woven through a number
of MCU movies for example Captain
America Civil War where the collateral
damage from the Avengers activities
became a global issue that led to the
sokovia accords as a way to attempt to
regulate the superhero teams activities
but by the end of infinity war we can
see that the cost for each of our
favorite heroes has become truly
personal Peter Parker dying in Tony
Stark's arms was an extremely emotional
moment for both the audience and of
course Tony who mentored the budding
superhero remember what Tony said to
Spidey after what happened with the
fairy in homecoming what if somebody had
died tonight different story right
because that's on you and if you died
that's like that's on me
I don't need that on my conscience Tony
did tried to stop Peter joining this
mission as he knew the journey to Titan
was too dangerous for the friendly
neighborhood spider-man
in fact Tony's worth that this isn't a
school trip it's a one-way tickets
turned out to be a heartbreaking bit of
foreshadowing and when everyone on titan
starts to cinder-gray sing in front of
Ironman I couldn't help but think of
Tony's vision and his interpretation of
that vision in age of Ultron I wasn't
tricked I was shown wasn't a nightmare
was my legacy the end of the path I
started us on watch my friends dive you
think that'd be as bad as it gets or
anything nope wasn't the worst part the
worst part that you didn't the Steve
Rogers or Captain America watching his
lifelong friend Bucky who fought so hard
to bring back from being brainwashed by
Hydra just evaporate into dust must have
been devastating after all they always
had each other's backs
I'm with you to the end of the line pal
[Music]
I'm not gonna fight you
you're my friend gives my theater the
NRO mine earlier in the film Scarlet
Witch told vision that taking his life
to destroy the mine stone was too high a
price but he told her that she was the
only one who had the power to pay it and
at the end not only did she have to
sacrifice her lover by blasting the mine
stone out of his forehead to obliterate
it but she then had to witness a NOS
reverse her actions before murdering
vision in a most horrible way and
ultimately she was snapped away herself
like vision gomorrah too was willing to
sacrifice her own life in an effort to
stop Thanos and similar to Scarlet Witch
star-lord made the awful decision to
take the life of gomorrah the woman he
loved as he'd promised her he'd do
though Thanos of course too used the
reality stone to turn quills blaster
into bubbles on top of that gomorrah
also had to make the terrible choice
between ending her sister nebulas
torture at the hands of Thanos and
giving the mad Titan exactly what he
wanted the location of the soul stone
Loki faced the same decision and after
saving his brother later paid the
ultimate price for trying to do the
right thing rather than allowing himself
with the mad Titan the god of mischief
has had heroic moments in previous films
such as saving his brother and Jane
Foster from the Dark Elves and Thor the
dark world but ultimately he used that
moment for his own gain to take the
throne but that was certainly not the
case this time Groot gave up one of his
arms both to save Thor and in service of
creating what the Asgardian God called
his Stannis killing weapon Stormbreaker
and thor who's lost his brother parents
friends and home over the years was also
willing to risk his own life as he
attempted to start the forges on knitter
Ballia for black panther the cost of
opening up work and ER to the world
turned out to be considerable as his
country and his people were at the very
center of Earth's battle against Thanos
and so many work and ins including
himself lost their lives ultimately each
of our heroes did pay the price and it
was certainly a hard and heavy one in a
way you could say this personal cost
that each character paid is what defines
them as a true hero but even when they
did what was necessary for the greater
good
done a huge personal cost at this point
it was seemingly all for nothing they
gave everything yet in the end they were
still defeated versus Steve Rogers said
to Tony Stark in civil war if someone
dies on a watch we don't give up and to
quote Nick Fury in the first Avengers
movie until such time as the world ends
we will act as Lord intends to spin on
as for the film's villain Thanos who saw
himself as a hero of the story and the
only one willing to do what was vital
for the universe even he had to pay a
price by sacrificing the daughter he
loved
now there's another interesting moment
where Thanos visits a mystery oranjee
red world my current theory is that this
is connected with the Infinity stones
and I'll talk more about that in a
separate video about how the soul stone
works I'll link it here as soon as it's
ready we've talked a lot about how
infinity war is not your typical Marvel
movie and that even carried over into
how the credits played out normally
there's a set of fancy credits
immediately after the last scene but
infinity war instead went for a simple
white text on black to reflect the
somber note the film ends on and it was
a rather creative choice when the
Avengers infinity war title that came on
at the usual mid-credits moment faded
into dust but of course there was still
one crucial post-credit scene that came
right at the end after all the credits
rolled in that scene we see the effects
of the snap rippling around the world in
this case New York City with Nick Fury
and Maria Hill and there's also a very
cool Captain Marvel teased I've already
done a full breakdown and explanation of
everything in that scene in my post
credits video which you can watch by
tapping right up here or clicking the
link in the video description below
so what do you think about the shocking
end of infinity war and how do you think
our heroes will defeat Thanos in
Avengers 4 let me know below and make
sure you're subscribed to my Avengers
Funko pop giveaway tap here put all my
latest infinity War and Marvel videos
including post credits breakdowns
interviews and Avengers for theories
thanks for watching and see you next
time here became movie lovers